Doogie wrote in I don't know if that's a
that's the real name Doogie says what
childish behaviors are too common in
adults sadly because maybe because we
work in politics and media I run into
lots of these all the time
treating others poorly I can't stand
when people adults treat others poorly
this applies to just out service workers
is a common one and I've talked about
this before if I go to a restaurant or a
bar and someone I'm with is rude to the
waitstaff my opinion of that person
immediately falls off a cliff because
there is no reason whatsoever to be
treating people poorly particularly
people who are providing a service to
you I don't know if you're bothered by
that pattern maybe you don't know people
who do this but I've been out with
people who start treating the waitstaff
really rudely and it is a major major
red flag to me right and what do they
end up doing afterwards they ask to
speak to a manager right and that ties
into this childish idea because I think
that's equivalent to going and telling
someone's mom what they did wrong lying
for no reason I know people who live for
absolutely no reason as adults and I
could speculate maybe maybe they think
that they're making themselves more
interesting by telling lies maybe they
believe that they are trying to create a
better image of who they are but adults
who lie for no reason and lie obviously
very very weird I don't I don't get that
and I know people Pat who are total
liars about anything and I just don't
even bother to follow up with them like
I just I know they're lying and I let
them lie and I don't care yeah I mean
I'm a consequentialist in the sense that
I think sometimes it's justifiable to
lie you know you can get you out of a
sticky situation for example but it's
just very strange when people lie
needlessly either to make themselves
sound cooler or a nicer or what-have-you
but sometimes even the objectives you
can't really understand why they would
make up the lie I think they're just
doing it for their own fun well that's
that's what makes me wonder if it's
actually some kind of diagnosing
condition right we hear about this this
idea of the pathological liar who seems
unable to
control they're lying I don't know
whether that's a diagnosable condition
or not but the level of lying that I see
some adults engage in makes me wonder
could this be anything other than
someone who has some kind of condition
that they can't control almost like
sometimes when people have Tourette
syndrome they can't they can't control
uh pterence --is of swears or other sort
of verbal things maybe there's some
equivalent with lying because I don't I
it's hard to understand it any other way
yeah there's always these fantastical
stories that happen in these people's
lives even though you know they just go
home every day and watch TV you know
this then happen Pat doesn't know people
who have those fantastical lives he
knows you're just going home and
watching Netflix after watching ok last
one just real quickly cutting in line ok
cutting in line at the deli cutting in
line at the grocery store cutting in
line boarding a plane we're adults here
don't cut in line we all see what you're
doing and it's absolutely an utterly
pathetic
okay great bonus show today a study is
supporting a Massachusetts timezone
change am i for or against it I'll tell
you on the bonus show plus much more
david pakman.com slash membership
patreon.com slash david pakman show both
give you instant access to the bonus
show